Hello Freak bitches saw
that his majesty thing,
right?
You saw that,
huh?
Oh,
you haven't seen this.
So University of Michigan,
like a lot of universities.
Yes.
Now doing this,
uh,
you know,
like you sign up for class,
your professor sends out an email to the
entire class and professor Joe Rogan,
my preferred pronouns are he him.
And then this one kid was able to cause
you can voluntary choose your pronoun.
He was like minus his majesty of it.
What a good kid.
His whole thing was to a
point out the absurdity of it,
but then people are like,
you're a fucking asshole.
Like they're all mad at him.
Now his name is grant Strobel.
Chairman of the young Americans Foundation
do use the new policy to update his
preferred Pronoun to His Majesty.
How could they be mad at him?
That is,
that is no more ridiculous than h.
I.
R of course there's like 18 different
gender pronouns now we've been identified
and we also know there's astral gendered.
If you're feeling like you're
part of the cosmos or eat Polly,
I'm Pauline by.
Yeah,
you put it on your,
your pot.
You put it on his podcast or
he's a Twitter page like a,
it was like by awareness day and then,
and then some,
some guy,
a real professor was
tweeting and he retweeted.
It wasn't something that
was so close to parity.
What the fuck did he say?
He was just like,
it was the wording of it was
too absurd to even recall.
But it was like,
remember when you're the teacher today on,
on um,
by awareness day,
your gender and your to be by
is not to be gender specific,
but your specific to city of your gender
can also dictate what your sexuality
might be like.
What,
like something like that.
Something,
I dunno.
And then it was like happy by awareness.
You know,
I finally used an all gender restroom in
Portland and it was at a gay bar and I
got,
I didn't enjoy it.
And it's not because of
the whole Pronoun thing.
It's because you've got like dude's
taking gnarly shits next to you.
That's an issue.
I don't need it.
Yeah.
I don't need it zooms
or is A's I'm and by,
and I'm also fluid gender.
My favorite thing is to be fluid gender
because you can go however you're
feeling in the moment,
but you have to,
people have to know what to call you,
so you have to,
that's my favorite.
Announce constantly that we want.
We saw this video of
this guy who was like,
he was like,
you know,
you should really respect
people's pronouns,
which,
which I owe.
I'm like,
okay.
Then he goes and if you see
somebody and you're not sure,
just ask them.
Be like,
Hey,
what's your pronoun?
To which I say,
no,
you fucking don't.
Like,
you're not going to just
see somebody and be like,
Hey,
hey,
I'm just wondering.
She pronouns.
I think that the elders
should be on the person.
The Steven Crowder.
Steven Crowder has a fucking hilarious
video where he actually does this and
he'll go,
yeah,
he goes out and asks people what
their preferred gender pronouns are.
And they,
there's the,
the looks they give him,
like he goes to like grown adults and it
goes up to them on the street and just
talks to them and just wonders what
their preferred gender Pronoun is.
Nobody knows what the
fuck you're talking about.
Preposterous.
I can't wait for the backlash is
what's that video of that Guy Dustin?
Dakota.
Yeah.
We'd have to show Joe that one.
Dakota is amazing.
Did you even see the thing?
Yeah,
to code is incredible.
This Zinzer Zinzer there's a,
Oh for the,
the different gender pronouns.
Why is it so hard?
Why can't you just do what they ask?
My pronouns are not preferred
c and the thing is like,
I feel like there's
enough people going okay,
really that it's kind of a legitimate
thing to not be 100% on board with us.
You know,
cause I feel a little like,
oh,
am I on the wrong end of
history are not preferred.
Ask a gender terrorist.
There you go.
Whoa.
This is the newest video on my Oscar
gender terrorist playlist on my channel.
Are we allowed to play this without,
Huh?
Yeah,
you can't.
You can't just play it.
Well,
we're not showing it on youtube.
Are we like picture in
picture about take it off.
Yeah,
take it off.
It's this dude's,
there's dude.
Whatever it is that's got a beard.
Not,
I know it doesn't have a
preferred gender pronoun.
Well that's what you're looking at.
We're going to get to,
so that's the thing now,
right?
You can kind of be
whatever you want to be.
Yeah,
which is fine.
I guess I just think it's funny that some
people are saying that you should see
this individual and lead with like,
it's like almost like it's
rude for you to assume,
which I think is absurd
that you're going to,
that it's rude to assume like if you,
if you're going to dictate
a different pronoun,
I think that should be on you.
Like a status.
Like you should just show people or some
people do have these little stickers
that they put on my
preferred gender Pronoun is.
That's cool.
Well,
here's a radio lab and this is
one of my all time favorite ones.
There's a radio lab podcast.
They take it so seriously
because it's radio lab and uh,
there's a guy on it who's clearly out
of his fucking mind and he goes back and
forth between male and female.
He switches while he's talking
to you because I just switched.
I just switched.
I'm the man now.
And you're like,
well,
okay,
when do you get to be a dragon?
Do you get to read minds when
this book tell the future?
Then we're supposed to respect this.
You have to because it's,
it has to do with gender.
So if this guy was telling
you about his past lives,
you know,
as a Roman gladiator or if he was telling
you about the future when the star
ships land,
you would think that he's a crazy person.
Right?
But I think it right now,
but we did talk about gender.
As soon as you start talking about gender,
you,
you really,
you're supposed to like give
people the benefit of all doubt.
Like even if you think you're switching
gender back and forth as you're talking,
like the idea that you're your genders,
like some sort of a seesaw,
you're on the precipice and you can just
go left or right to left or right and
it is you just close minded asshole.
You just decide.
Yeah.
You don't understand Joe.
But here's the thing,
are we different a lot of the time?
Yes.
Why can't be expressed in gender like
you the other day when you're cranky
because you didn't get your sugar.
Yeah,
right?
Yeah.
Like what dance,
right?
You have a different personality trait.
You fell into this bitchy it
doesn't like but doesn't like that.
That feeling that the going back like
sexist and need a fire join up jetboat
phobic nervous.
Well,
I'm looking forward.
I'm looking forward to ignoring so many
emails that are going to come into my
inbox about this conversation,
but too,
but people get mad.
Oh,
I know they're going to get so mad.
My point is like,
we've talked about this,
like if you're feeling
particularly lovie dovie right,
you're the pet and kittens and you're,
you're putting your
daughter's hair in ponytails.
[inaudible] it's a more feminine feeling.
So did you switch genders at that moment?
No.
You still specifically,
this guy wanted to go back and forth
to being recognized as a man and then
recommend the middle of the conversation
and then as he goes back and forth,
he becomes a totally different person.
Like,
yes.
Like he's not going to
tolerate any bullshit.
I think usually in the military too.
I was like,
it was like,
hmm.
There's a lot of weirdness to the story.
And he's under the care
of a psychiatrist though,
right?
No,
no,
no.
He's wondering around getting
government grants and great.
Oh Wow.
I have no idea.
I have no idea what he's doing.
But um,
I just,
you never go.
Like if someone goes back and
forth and pretends to be Hungarian,
I'm Hungarian.
No,
I'm not.
no,
no.
I'm from Ireland right now,
but I feel today I'm
now I'm Hungarian again.
Right.
I'm identifying that way.
But
fine.
Like,
here's the thing,
if you want to identify
throughout the day,
sometimes I am more masculine.
When I'm at the comedy store performing,
I am very alpha male.
I'm very,
it's macho,
but I do,
I have to demand that people know
what to call me at every given moment.
That's a little unrealistic.
What's a new thing?
I mean it's so presumptuous.
A narcissistic that you
should know what to call.
Does this person at
least say like right now,
address me as her,
right?
Yeah.
My shooter for names.
He looks snip and you just
see the shit out of them.
Depending on who I'm,
I might be mis-gendering or not depending
on how he here or she hears it at the
moment when you get points,
if you're in a conversation
with that person,
yeah.
Would you cope like you
feel like that's a respect,
like something that you'd be like,
oh,
okay,
I'll,
I'll respect your wishes.
I'm not changing your gender.
You gotta pick one.
Yeah.
If you say,
girl,
Oh,
okay,
you're a girl.
I'm cool with that.
I don't have any problem with that.
But you can't go back and forth.
Yeah.
Okay.
Where I can't talk to you.
Yeah,
it's too much work is in other words.
Yeah.
I think that's the whole thing.
It's too much fucking work.
And if you're an adult,
it's got a full life.
How the fuck are you have room in your
head for the Zim Jerseys every second
changing.
Well,
not only that,
that's somebody else's issue.
Right?
What about yourself?
You know,
I don't have any,
I don't even be room to communicate
with you because you're concentrating on
yourself so much.
You want people to
change how they address.
You just can you just change how you
feel occasionally and not have a new
fucking name three
o'clock in the afternoon.
Now I'm Bob.
Why did we have to label
it every moment of every,
well,
it's a super self indulgent thing and
that's what you're getting out of this and
that's what like the people that are,
you know,
they're being labeled as insensitive.
Like that's kind of the point.
The point is like,
yeah,
you're supposed to be
insensitive of nonsense.
This deserves a fair amount of mockery.
The Fairmount afraid to in part because
we're going to get shamed on Twitter.
People are going to call
us phobic of this and that.
Even if you say something remotely
on politically correct or whatever.
Yeah.
Look,
there's a bunch of people out there that
are just not happy and they might not
be happy with the gender.
They might not be happy
with the way they look.
with how old they are.
They might not be happy with
a bunch of different things,
but we have like rules as far as like
what you can change and what you can't
change and we're allowing people now this
is like a really recent thing to just
decide to change your gender,
which doesn't affect me.
I want people to have freedom,
doesn't bother me,
but what?
What is this?
There's an addendum to
the radio lab story.
She made them edit out the references
to her actually changing her identity.
I guess she stopped,
she stopped switching after all this
right here and she no longer flips.
Interesting.
Hmm.
She now remains comfortable
as a queer trans woman.
What does,
what does that mean?
What's like,
it's not queer.
There's not gay though.
No,
I thought it meant that
queer is like weird.
Like you can do both,
right?
Isn't it?
What does queer then let,
how do you
know gay is gay?
Queer is not gay.
Queer.
It's like non defined.
Okay,
so and not a non defined trail on binary.
That's Tom's domain.
Tom,
can you explain this?
I mean basically,
well you guys,
you fall on the binary spectrum.
Cisgendered privileging.
Okay,
here we go.
Shit.
A queer feeling.
Nope.
That's not it.
A homosexual.
No,
no.
See they're using a different,
now see it used to be homosexual,
but it's not just a homosexual anymore.
Okay.
Terms and definitions.
Lbgt right there.
Click on that one.
Lgbtq now.
Oh No,
there's an I and an a in
there to look at that.
See,
look at that.
Make that largest fucking shitty.
Ask you read it.
Bisexual,
transgender credit.
Yeah,
look at it.
But look at above.
Above,
above the top loop.
LG,
LGBT,
ga.
What is TB?
Lg.
Queer.
Asexual,
queer or asexual or
questioning and asexual or,
but there's intersexual too.
There's I,
some people choose.
I wait,
what's that?
What does that all,
no,
let's get to Q queer,
Intersex as Jamie,
an umbrella term used by l g B t Q.
A people to revert to the entire L.
G.
B t community and alternative that some
people used to queer is the idea that
labels and categories such as lesbian,
gay,
bisexual,
etc. Similar to the concept
of Queer of gender queer.
Oh,
okay.
Gender.
Queers different.
Hmm.
What's Gender Queer?
I think that'd be like me.
Like nonbinary don't fall under
the spectrum of male or female.
Gender Queer is a term which refers to
individuals or groups who are queer or
problematize what they're making,
a fake words,
hegemonic notions of sex,
gender,
and desire.
In a given society,
gender queer people possess identities
which fall outside of the widely accepted
sexual binary.
You're not mine.
Your area,
your gender queer,
Bro.
Yeah.
Gender Queer.
Jan Mueller may also refer to
people who identify as both trend,
gendered end queer.
I individuals who,
Huh?
This is a lot of work,
man.
That's a lot of work time.
This is what you do when
you don't chop firewood.
Yeah.
She was a fucking easy to get water.
It's too easy.
Just get bottled water too easy society.
We have to invent all of these things
now and they didn't have taken that
Muskrat shit in my mouth.
This is a real hate mail episode.
We always bring the hate
the gender stuff this time.
You know what the real
gender stuff though.
No,
no,
no.
The fake stuff.
No,
not the legit people.
They're like,
dude,
I'm a,
I'm a man trapped in a woman's,
but that I do obviously.
Right,
but just keep yourself,
take your weird shit.
That shit suppressors.
Exactly.
Persons good.
I'm telling you the 1950s not all bad.
No,
but you know,
there was,
keep on the right track.
Gender people pour in
the turn of the century,
the turn of the 20th century.
There's a lot of photos of
transgender people from back then.
It's always been a thing.
I used to see them more and in Hollywood
where I live there about 15 years ago,
I just don't buy the going back and forth.
Sorry.
Yeah,
I,
yeah.
I don't,
I don't think most most people do.
I think it's an attention seeking,
uh,
some something,
something else is going on there.
I think not all your feelings
should be acknowledged by agree.
That's important.
Right.
I agree.
That's important.
You like this.
The guy wants to be the six year old girl.
I mean,
they have all these specials on
him and now he's 57 years old.
I can't,
they don't have specials on him
because he's an extraordinary story.
They have specials on
him because you know,
it's ridiculous and
you're going to watch it.
Yeah.
It's funny.
Yes.
Yeah.
It's weird.
You,
you'll let,
you can't go back in time.
Right.
You lived a long time.
You have to be responsible.
You have a special on him.
The same reason they have a special on
a lady who doesn't cut her toenails.
Like,
these are my special name.
It's so true and I can't get a job.
Right.
And they can never get a job.
That's the downer.
Nowadays,
people are employable.
That is the one common denominator.
Okay.